das finde ich gut das war's
hallöchen bei der lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge der today show folge 25
sind wir glaube ich mittlerweile immer
noch zusammen mit den und heute unser
heutiger gast ist
hallo hallo ihr habt ihr abitur ketter
also an die leute die bei mir gerade
gucken genau ganz ganz ganz ganz am
anfang
ich glaube ich war ich glaub ich auch
tausend abonnenten das waren bei welchen
witz und 14 wind damals war es noch
witzig so hast du damals auch gerochen
und ich hatte glaube ich keine ahnung
auch irgendwie 1500 attentäter gemacht
und da ich dachte anders punkten schade
schade schade
mein schwert ist fast kaputt nur winken
1.4 haben
was haben wir in der 1 das stimmt
irgendwie schneller kaputt
sie scheren haben sounds um einen gott
und man ja doch ja ganz ganz klein
bisschen also damit die leute auch
wissen die bei mir zu gucken grad
es ist meine aufgabe hier ein häuschen
zu bauen innerhalb von einigen folgen
was ihm bei mein bestes versuchen sein
gesammeltes wissen dass wir immer themen
haben da haben wir gerade schon gesagt
aber das ist ja was an deine zuschauern
das heißt diesmal hat den er sich die
ganzen kann ich dich eigentlich wären
damit jetzt das thema vorbereitet falls
ich hab also viele namen vorbereitet die
frage ist welche wir anfangen oder darm
erst richtig interessant heißt das stück
ist aber bedienen
ich habe richtig bock zu diskutieren wir
können ja mal was anfangen mit dem mit
dem us-wahlkampf von the brew denn mein
team vorschlag waren in den usa glaubt
ihr es ging mit romney oder doch eher
mit obama findet ihr die amerikanische
bevölkerung verblendet oder verblödet
finde ich gut was darf ich eure kissen
einfach drin wenn ich etwas finde was
ich brauche am besten fragt wenn möglich
immer weiß was wegnimmt oder kuckucken
erstmal park oder 120 schweine kamen
natürlich am besten nehmen weil für
steinwerkzeuge eisen habe selber kaum
doch es habe ich habe wie gesagt nur ein
holz werkzeuge von du hast glaube ich
gar nicht viel drin natürlich open ins
gleisen fächer kann sich eisenberg zwei
mitmachen siehst du das auch im ofen im
gebot versteckt luca keine am anfang mit
seinem meinung zu diesem thema usa
wahlkampf ohne witz egal was ich jetzt
sagen werde den als eher dagegen
na gut ich finde das ist allgemein jetzt
mal gemeinsam zum zum wählen in amerika
das ist dort alles komplett anders
gehandhabt als in deutschland also
natürlich dürfen die darf da natürlich
das volk wählen aber ich finde da
herrscht eine komplett andere euphorie
also das geht richtig alles auf allen
sendern immer an und laura und keine
ahnung als ich es gab jetzt auch drei
von diesen öffentlichen ich wollte schon
rap battles sagen von diesen sprach
battle zwischen der stingray gtr
zwischen obama und ron davis richtig und
es ist uns einmal zwischen den
kandidaten dazu eine agenda und es ist
auch so dass habe ich nämlich im
fernsehen gesehen dass romney wohl mehr
teile auf seiner seite hat also mehr
starten
die halt so durchschnittlich für oneway
sind als obama das heißt ich denke es
wird total eng natürlich werden viele
obama wählen und sagen hey der deutschen
was angefangen er muss das jetzt
irgendwie fortsetzen ob aber der steht
ja auch oft in der kritik von daher will
ich sagen das leben ganz ganz ganz ganz
knappes ding und das merkt man auch
daran wie viel die wirklich dann auch
irgendwie rein investieren in den
werbekampagnen und alles weitere sei
also werben
das jetzt falsch angewandt aber ich
würde sagen es wird richtig richtig
knapp und ich denke dass romney
sommergewinn jetzt der super gewinnt
einfach weil konkrete das nicht denkt
ich jetzt mal ein mba also erstmals das
natürlich ein total person fixierter
wahlkampf so ganz anders als bei uns na
also
natürlich wird man bei uns auch in den
mit mit der parteien war auch den
kanzler irgendwie mit aber salz in den
usa deutlich stärker person fixiert und
wie solche servicekräften jetzt muss ich
erst mal ein malkurs einmal kurz kräften
du kannst ja jetzt erst mal zum
wahlsystem in den usa sehr schön sein
gesprochen dass man eine bestimmte
anzahl an staaten hinter sich haben muss
sozusagen weil dort geht es nicht danach
wer jetzt zum beispiel 50 60 prozent
aller deckt kompletten bevölkerung
hinter sich hat es präsident sondern er
muss 60 prozent aller staaten also
hinter sich haben
wie viel staat nun die 50 51 52
doch das ist ganz ganz komplizierter und
zwar erst das schon lange gerne ich
nämlich gibt nämlich staaten starten wie
zum beispiel weiß nicht was gibt's da
textes oder so die halt die sind zwar
sehr groß aber mehr nicht einwohner und
da kann es natürlich nicht sein dass nur
weil die so groß sind haben jetzt in
größeren einfluss als zum beispiel
california nun aber die haben natürlich
die mehr einwohner als es wird ja alles
schon berechnet und zwar hat jeder staat
glaube ich noch mal eigene ließen die
jedermann am 12 oder was auf englisch
jetzt auf englisch
aber an sich meinte wahrscheinlich die
wahlmänner und 2 wird deshalb aber nicht
die partei sondern man wählt die
wahlmänner die jeder dann hier wählen
müssten dann nachher aber sie müssen
nicht mal das wählen was sie eigentlich
vorher vorgegeben haben immer in manchen
staaten das unter strafe wenn die
wahlmänner was falsch ist etwas anderes
wählen als eigentlich sie wählen sollte
manchen aber nicht wenn das habe ich das
gar nicht so als enkes endgültige
problem weil die meistens schon wählen
was ich wählen sollten
das ding ist halt nur dass the winner
takes it all das heißt wenn jetzt in
florida jemand 51 prozent und einer 49
prozent dann bekommt ihr alle wahlmänner
bekommt der gewinner und der verlierer
bekommt keinen einzigen wallmann und so
werden halt die wahlen entschieden und
zum beispiel 2000 bei der walbusch ging
al gore hat bush hatte insgesamt weniger
stimmen den ganzen usa
ich glaube eine halbe million weniger
stimmen so was in den drei bars und
trotzdem hat er gewonnen weil er in
florida war am ende der der wackel punkt
der knackpunkt hatte er auch nur ganz
paar mehr stimmen und dadurch hat er
alle wahlmänner bekommen und das steht
auch alles unter kritik und das ist es
wurde mehrfach bei ausgezählt
gerichtsurteil und so was also um sehr
umstritten und bis heute
verschwörungstheorien das eigentlich
echo geehrt
das ist wieso immer punkt um 1
verschwörungen ich bin mir selber muss
ich sagen nicht immer ganz sicher ob das
ganze abläuft bei den wahlen ich meine
ist schon klar allgemeiner politik
kannst du das nicht wirklich sagen genau
so ein brennpunkt sage ich mal was
stimmt jetzt gerade in amerika wo es so
ist dass es ist ja anders als in
deutschland wo also ich bestreite dass
immer gerne so als propaganda denkmal
das exzessive werbung auf eine ganz
spezielle sache das ist ja hier in
deutschland gar nicht so erhält man
vielleicht irgendwo plakate oder sogar
dort ist so der präsident fährt um die
wollen aktiv stimmen machen wie steigern
sich da richtig rein alle menschen
steigern sich daran und ich weiß nicht
ob ich war schon
das gefühl dass das ein bisschen
gehirnwäsche ist so beispielsweise der
präsident lässt sich in irgend einem
städtchen blicken etwas kleiner
vielleicht und ja und alle sind hin und
weg und dann wählen sie ihn zb rwe hält
eben die person in ihrer regierung die
halt eben für ihn stimmen würde ja
natürlich das ist ja auch so da das
burgfest gar nicht mehr wer das war
die halten auch reden in verschiedenen
ortschaften dann zum beispiel als er die
mannschaften jetzt klein beziehung
sondern auch in relativ großen orten und
die versuche natürlich überall ihre
leute anzuwerben um sie selber zu wählen
und deswegen haben die auch immer ganz
viele verschiedene ziele an die sie sich
richten aber es gibt ja schon einmal
diesen unterschied dass bombay natürlich
ich glaube der war es der mehr ich
besser ist das aber gar nicht so genau
dass der sich mehr für die wirtschaft
ist und man noch weiß dass er da mehr
reissen kann aus früheren situation kann
das vielleicht auch sein weil ihm seine
meisten befürworter vielleicht in den
industriestaaten hat von den usa war
keine ahnung aber ich weiß dass romney
auf jene rod laver früher war früher mal
war hedgefonds-manager also in dem
bereich dass er firmen aufgekauft hat
zwar teils ganz viele mitarbeiter das
merken wie gemacht hat mitarbeiter nach
china verlegt also arbeitsplätze nach
china verlegt hat nicht mitarbeiter
sondern arbeitsplätze und soll es der
große sanierer und natürlich auch
milliardär aber das ist obamas auch für
motoren oder nur multi mio diese müssen
ja allen usa und präsident zu werden
brauchst du musst du millionär
ja denn sie legionär oder im mega der
seien schon fast das habe ich letztens
auch gesehen und zwar in seiner
reportage oder so da haben die gezeigt
wie es halt eben für die kinder der
präsidentin ist mit den eltern halt eben
auch wahlkampf zu sein
da haben die auch also muss ich sagen
das war wirklich übertrieben
also die müssen ja selber schon ein mega
vermögen haben und sozusagen um daran
teilnehmen zu können weil die zahlen
alles aus eigener tasche
und wenn ihr sozusagen verlieren
rentiert sich ja gar nichts das heißt
die verlieren ja alles für nichts
deswegen ist es so wichtig spenden
einzusammeln und darum haben auch die
superreichen die also die die großen
beträge spenden können so einen großen
einfluss auf die politiker ja ob das
jetzt gut
die andere frage weil ich meine
ausgeschlossen
richtig gut ist das eine mit sicherheit
nicht man kann eigentlich schon sagen
dass ich die wahlkandidaten in amerika
wirklich die stimmen erkaufen mehr oder
weniger weil natürlich durch
werbeplakate durch werbekampagnen wenn
da auf dem times square zum beispiel
sonst zehn sekunden spot von obama
gezeigt wird wir irgendwie kleinen
mädchen oder genau irgendwie so dann
denken sich die alle ja der ist total
nett kommt in den wald sind da fährt er
millionen von euros ausgeben dollar
ausgegeben die machen ja die spielen ja
extra mit den gezielten reizen zum
beispiel das schon entdeckens in den
kopf gekommen ist mit dem kleinen
mädchen die an oder er lässt sich auf
dem land blickt das zeigt dass ab oder
bodenständig ist den covern vertrauen
und wieso spielen wieder fehlen
einzelner menschen
er geht sehr stark nach so was also die
inhalte stehen häufig sehr im
hintergrund und was sehr extrem wird bei
diesem präsidentschafts debatten das
recht manchmal als zum beispiel in der
ersten debatte war es so dass romney
gesagt hat m hat sie sind seine neuen
steuer plan mit dem er weniger steuern
für die mittelschicht also die
mittelschicht soll entlastet werden
müssten weniger steuern zahlen und
trotzdem ist es für den muss der staat
dafür hat keine mindereinnahmen und
demokratische die analysten rechnen
immer mit einem bei diesem raum ney
planer mit dass fünf milliarden auf
englisch verbessern 5 millionen
da haben wir keine milliarde medien und
bilden die atrium was sag ich dir
überhaupt das sind mit es sind millionen
im deutschen und trillian schon im
amerikanischen also filmzeit scheißegal
man 5 million us dollars die das halt
dieser plan einigt kostet und in
einfacher net tv debatte gesagt leider
stimmt nicht es kostet nicht mehr
doch es kostet mir und es kostet die
autobahn obama einfach denn die frage
ist hat er dann wirklich ich meine haben
sie agieren haben sie danach nach der
debatte so analysiert entfernen im
amerikanischen fernsehen die armee aber
seine träume gewonnen mir aber das finde
ich ja mal nichts dagegen gesagt hat mir
meine kostet nicht mehr
ich meine da hat man über habe ich
irgendwie den eindruck wenn ich das ich
habe das nicht gesehen aber da kommt es
mir direkt da fällt mir das auf war hat
er dann wirklich den plan selbst gemacht
wenn er das nicht näher erläutern kann
ich meine nur da kommt nicht mehr das
hört sich so nach kindischen partie im
verhalten als hatte den plan gar nicht
selber gemacht oder irgendwie so
natürlich - länder aber wenn sie jetzt
schon selber mitgemacht aber auch ganz
viel andere ist ja logisch dass ein
politiker selber machen sonst seien 3000
berater hat
bush hatte von seinen hat von seinen
beratern sind großteils sind dieselben
gerate wie die die bush die ganze zeit
hatte in seine präsidentschaft jahren
also bush junior aber dass er den plan
einfach es ist einfach dass die einfache
bevölkerung dem er es glaubt und darum
hat also lügens in anführungszeichen
die frage ist doch was ist eigentlich
eine dreiste lüge will ich sie für seine
dreiste lüge und nach der debatte hat
obamas auch so klar gestellt
doch ich halt mal nachfragen ich bau
mein haus hier hinten wo ihr die drei
fackeln sieht ist das in ordnung wenn du
von contrast das häuschen gerät schicken
oder cook saniert kann sich auch luca
luca nicht luca
jetzt weiß ich dass genug holz nrw das
letztens erst gesehen dass du in foto
gepostet hast wie in der freistunde
irgendwas gemalt hass und der titel war
so nein das ist nicht konkreter und es
sollte es einer denken habe ich eine
instagram gesehen dass du das gleiche
foto dann noch mal gepostet hat und da
waren ihm die 5 kommentare
auf dem bild war erst bei instagram und
dann nochmal für facebook aber denn
jetzt kommt noch von woanders her weil
ein partybild mit einem kumpel von mir
war da und da waren kommentare das kaum
kräfte aus dass party peter bei facebook
betreibt und an meinem privaten profil
war das nie gut drauf markiert und man
kann mein privates profil zwar
abonnieren aber nicht freund werden
davon
die haben halt meinen namen haben sie
halt damals rausbekommen ganz viele über
ein anderes projekt was ich gemacht
hatte und gepostet hatte einen anderen
film über wunder bilder ziemlich
ziemlich gar ein spar das hat der film
aber so hat man mein name rauskommen
steinen kommentaren hier hast du felix
verladen und dann als einfach mal
klarzustellen ist das halt öffentlich
das profil und man kann das abonnieren
dann sieht man öffentliche einträge und
halt die die die partyveranstalter nimmt
eine story die ja mal dass ein bild
gepostet wo ich drauf habe ich darauf
markiert dann was in meinem profil und
dann aber darauf verlinkt und dann
konnte jeder darunter kommentare
schreiben
nicht nur meine freunde sondern jeder
auf ganz facebook und roland graf da ja
noch mal kommst du das jetzt zu ende zu
bringen und zwar schon längst wieder bei
15 minuten aber ich war doch ganz kurz
was sagen und zwar ich habe
persönlichkeit von diesen von diesen
debatten da gesehen gegen dann aber die
wurde halt alle großen fernseher
übertragen aber ich glaube zum beispiel
die dritte wurde das war zu unserer zeit
vier uhr nachts ungefähr da jetzt nicht
der oder drei börsen heute guckt ja
jedenfalls habe ich geguckt aber ich
weiß zum beispiel dass obama auch immer
romney fertig macht bei facebook zum
beispiel kostet ja immer bilder
haha ich mache hier das hier und was man
da gar nix und so also können wir das
national sondern richtig heftiger kampf
zwischen den beiden ist nicht so dass er
alle wirklich nur für sich was sagen
sondern auch gegen die anderen da immer
das sind schon ein paar feindschaft und
also natürlich die wollen ja ihre leute
da gewinnen aber ich will es angefangen
jetzt direkt mit einem thema anna und
ihr könnt aber nochmal in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr es gut finden wenn wir
träumen solange also die ganze folge
behandeln oder wer mit die immer nur so
kurz machen ja den
damals war so dass wir die echtem extrem
kurz gemacht haben ja und dann über
andere themen wie was ist dein
lieblingsessen
ja das was die fragen hast du raus also
ich hab jetzt solche rein